alright let's get started thank you
everybody for showing up at 9 o'clock on
Thursday morning
I very much appreciate it it's great to
see you here
weathers a little better so hopefully
today is more fun for everyone
um I guess we've already jumped ahead to
our extended version of the title of
this talk and we just stuck with what's
new and notifications and Android and
okay I see what it is I'm just resting
my thumb on the advancer and so that's
the problem
we definitely rehearse this I swear I
promise to everybody I'll bump back here
for a little bit and just try it say
we're gonna talk about notifications
today but we're gonna spend about half
our time talking about Android wear 2.0
because that got a great big review
yesterday at the keynote and I thought
the comedy session was this evening not
not right now all right well we'll deal
with it my name is Dan Sandler I'm the
lead engineer on the Android system UI
team which is EV all of the stuff you
can see on the screen that's not any
other app and I'm Alex Hills I am an
engineer on the wear system UI team
which has the exact same description but
smaller and attached to a body advancing
some to still advance oh man this thing
is this it's it's on its own alright
we're just gonna keep moving so we've
made some changes in Android
notifications this year we make some
changes every year this is kind of a big
change this year because we've messed
with the templates I mean you see here
we've actually messed with the templates
many times in the past this is probably
our first big I'm just gonna set this
down I'm just gonna set that thing down
we'll advance maybe by hitting the arrow
buttons in and we've changed it again
but the reason we've changed it is to
bring things more in line with material
design and to make things a little more
scannable generally we've got room for a
little more text you have the ability to
okay I actually do need to do the builds
now all right here we go
fantastic
okay so we've made that we've cleaned
things up they're a little less busy
we've hit our material key lines now
instead of winging it like we did before
you now see that we can tell you exactly
which app posted each notification
that's accountability for you the end
user which we never really had before
unless you knew to long press in the
notification so that's good and we've
taken the icons out of actions mostly so
that you've got more room for those long
labels that might show up in some
translations and then finally my
personal pet peeve about notifications
since we introduced expandable
notifications in jellybean is that you
can now tell what's expandable there's
an expansion widget a little chevron
that appears next to the app name that
lets you see oh there's more text here
and if I touch that you can actually
click it and it expands the notification
just this slide here is there anything
that we can do to avoid like racing
through I mean I race through stuff
anyway but I mean this is ridiculous all
right we're gonna hold it right there
let's see let's see what happens I move
the mouse around I'll turn around three
times in spit if that doesn't work hi
this is a slide that you're not supposed
to be able to follow it's like a London
Tube map which I certainly can't follow
I just want to move ate that all of the
old information is still here in the
templates to just move down it around to
a new place so if you're already using
the notification builder api's will take
care of all that for you we'll move it
into new spots another thing that's
useful to know particularly as an end
user is sort of where you can actually
touch on things
so here the hit targets I just want to
make a note that even though that expand
indicator is really small the hit target
forward is really big you touch anywhere
on that top row you expand the whole
notification so if you as a developer
have been using expanded notifications
and you're worried that like no user
knows how to find it this is how there's
a button you can touch finally after
three years so I mean you can touch
buttons applause seriously and I don't
know what this thing this thing really
likes me to do so what do you have to do
if you're using the Builder like I said
you don't have to do everything
everything is already going to be moved
to the new templates for you if you're
doing custom remote you remote views you
have a lot of work to do as you have
every single other release because
remote views you have to Reese Culp
everything from scratch to make sure
that it matches the new template design
but help is finally on the way for the
very first time we have a new template
that is just designed to say hey I've
got some custom content to put in the
middle of this view but please system
decorate the rest of it exactly the way
I suppose
to be done so we call it decorated
medias are a decorated custom view style
and what you can see here is essentially
a schematic of the orange section you
just do whatever you want inside a
remote views just like you did before
with custom remote views but the system
will then put in the expanded indicator
the app accountability the app name at
the top and even putting the actions for
you at the bottom so if you've got a
custom weather widget or something like
that but you want to have it match the
system style you're good to go another
big new thing that is new and an we
didn't talk about it much at the keynote
yesterday but if you've been playing
along at home with the n Developer
Preview you've seen this is that we are
now finally finally finally supporting
groups on the phone um use this one all
right thanks lemon we have an amazing
crew here today thank you very much we
actually added a notification group to
all the way back in API 20 for Android
wear and of course you've got this
awesome screenshot from like centuries
ago showing the original wear point at
one point Oh view of how the
notification groups look is a stack of
cards and on the phone yeah you just see
a summary right you just see one thing
usually you do inbox style to mask over
what would have otherwise been a group
of really nice notifications now you can
do this on the phone as well and on
tablets it the exact same API is move
forward so if previously your app was
you know doing some sort of you know
looking around to see if the wear
companion was installed don't do that
anymore just post all of your
notifications in that group which you
associate by group key and they'll show
up this way each one of those
notifications is its own full
notification so it can be expanded it
can have its own actions and everything
it's really really outstanding if you
haven't used this API before it's really
easy to do you say set group when you're
building a notification with builder the
string that you pass basically becomes a
collocation key that we use to collect
groups together by name you still want
to use a summary notification for two
reasons one this is what will show on
phones pre n right because we don't know
how to do groups pre end so we just show
this summary but in n we'll take that
summary and we'll extract little bits
and pieces of it to make you see that
little that little header row right at
the top above the bundle we actually
pull that information from the summary
so if for example you're displaying
group that represents one inbox right or
one account in your map
that might be the place that because of
the summary we know okay that's the
account name and that's what we'll put
in that summary row but then they each
individual conversation or each
individual email thread then goes into
its own notification in the group and
finally if you want to make sure that
those things up here in the correct
order use set sort key will just sort
them again on that string
lexicographically to make sure the
notification is show up exactly the way
you want them to see the other big
end-user feature on now it's not going
all right there we go
the other big end-user feature for
notifications in end that you developers
need to know about is direct reply and
we had this on where as well where you
could essentially post a notification
that somebody could then talk to the
watch and then that text that
immediately be sent back to the app and
you can send an SMS with it now we have
it on the phone and in fact you just
type directly into the notification
shade itself it's really awesome
particularly from the lock screen so
I've got a nice little build here you
can see you got a new message you touch
reply and you're just typing right in
there even if it's on the lock screen
it's fantastic if you've never used this
API before because again it's it was
introduced with API 24 where if you've
never used it before you want to build
something called remote input remote
input is something you hang off of an
action that says by the way if you know
how to send me text back please do it in
this way and so you set up a specific
key so that when you get your intent
back from that action click you can
extract out the text that was entered
something I want to point your attention
to if you've already been using a remote
input you probably have an activity
there as the pending intent on the on
the input in and it really really needs
to be for that action it means to be a
service or a broadcast receiver and
here's why if you have an action within
activity intent on the lock screen the
lock screen is going to say oh the user
wants to go somewhere when I click this
thing and it's gonna pop up that
authentication challenge it's going to
pop up the pin pad or the pattern or
fingerprint or what have you but what
you want to do for a remote input where
you want the user to be able to just
type straightaway on the lock screen is
make sure it goes to a background thing
like a broadcast receiver or a service
so that there's no authentication
required now if you're panicking and
saying oh oh hang on I don't want my
users to be you know allow people to
send SMS is on their behalf from the
lock screen that is an end-user setting
so if you go into settings as a user you
can say do I want to
be able to type in two things on my lock
screen or not so that's covered by
system settings you don't have to worry
about it all you have to do is make sure
that that remote input is available for
users who do want to opt into that
feature to just type type away from the
lock screen or anywhere else one last
thing I do want to point out when you
set up that room Wow
you know what I'm glad this is happening
here in this room as opposed to like
yesterday during the keynote I'm cool
with that so when you've got your
broadcast receiver you just want to make
sure you use this method remote input
get results from intent that's the way
that you extract that text back out and
all of this sample code is just stolen
mercilessly from our developer Docs so
particularly if you download DP 3 the
Developer Preview for Android all this
stuff is going to be in there you don't
have to copy it down you can sketch in
Odin if you want you'll be able to pull
this directly into your app and get
remote input running another thing that
I wanted to mention is after you get a
reply so so here's the flow you post a
notification the user touches reply it
types directly in it you get the intent
back extract the text great this is what
the user wanted to send as a comment or
an SMS or whatever what do you do now so
previously when people do direct reply
there our pattern was that you just
dismissed the notification you assume
the user is done with it not anymore we
assume now that in an a user is going to
decide to dismiss that notification
whatever they want
this way they can post you know one or
two quick messages in rapid succession
without losing that context so after you
get a remote input direct reply leave
the notification up and more than that
you actually want to re notify to
signify oh yeah we got it
we got this it's been posted and we have
this API called set remote input history
that basically all it does is draws a
little line underneath your existing
notification content whatever it was and
then puts in any reply text that you
want so you can make a UI like this
where you say oh you've left that
comment and the user knows okay this
transaction has been completed I don't
have to wonder whether it's been posted
I'm set so this works really well for
something like leaving a comment on a
picture or something like that where you
have the original notification content
and then you've got replies that sit
after it but that doesn't really work
all that well for a chat because chats
are back and forth right you say
something they say something you say
something they says something set remote
input history it doesn't quite cover
that case we've got something even
better
but I'm gonna hold that off and let Alex
talk about that because that's real fun
in fact why don't you go ahead and get
started that the clickers fidgety maybe
it likes you better than me
let might it might or maybe it'll
advance seven times for each time I
click that's right great all right so
dance told you a little bit about how n
brings some pretty big changes to the
visual style of notifications on the
phone well I think that I'm gonna one-up
him and say that Android wear 2.0 is the
biggest notification redesign in the
history of Android wear which also
happens to be the only notification
redesign in the history of Android wear
but I got one up Dan anyway so you know
I'll take it before I start I do want to
mention briefly that while this section
applies to all notifications on wear
it's mostly geared towards bridge
notifications coming from a phone app if
you want to learn some other ways to
approach this for notifications coming
from a local wear app you can go to the
making wear apps more standalone talk at
2:00 p.m. or view our deaf Doc's it
doesn't like me there we go so the very
first impression that a user gets of
your apps notification is the card
itself in the context Stream let's talk
a little bit of history in Android wear
1x cards were cool you can specify
different card heights at big background
images for visual context you could toss
in or hide a small icon or a Content
icon and get all sorts of different
fonts and treatments all these features
provide a lot of visual richness and
impact to the cards themselves that said
the richness could sometimes backfire
like when the background image itself
was mostly obscured by the card itself
or diversed font treatments made it hard
for a user to actually determine what
was most important for a notification at
a glance we thought about this but what
the purpose of a notification card is
about the importance of high glance
ability and change things around a
little bit in where 2.0 notification
cards now look a little different
visually all the same components are
there like when I promise they're all
there but we've made them a little more
consistent and more information first
we've switched from our card base design
to a dark bold material theme we now use
color to start telling the story the
color that you app that your app sets in
the notification now applies to the
entire notification surface immersing
the user in your content explicit
typography
intentional treatment help give the user
focus for the most important information
first the color treatment also serves to
bring a bit of visual consistency and
coherence to the notification because
you set the color from your app
notifications coming from you look like
they're coming from you
a notifications coming from another app
look like they're coming from another
app the other part of this material
update is a set of changes to the layout
of the card itself remember though like
I said before all the same content is
there you can look at this right over
there and trust me
got it list it out and broken out for
you it's just switched around a little
bit first off we take a
one-size-fits-all approach to the actual
notification all notifications are the
same size one screen no more different
card heights second we've taken the
large icon in the background that nice
rich icon there and we've brought it to
the front of front and center of the
notification it's no longer partially
obscured by the card or anything like
that we've also brought yes we've also
brought the small icon from the card
itself to well it's still actually on
the notification but we brought it down
to the bottom right of that large icon
finally the content text and title are
centered we've made the font treatment a
little more consistent with an emphasis
on glance ability now that you know what
your notification looks like I'm going
to put it in the context of the actual
system a little bit more history and
Android wear 1x the contact stream could
be a bit confusing to navigate the
stream was ostensibly a single and
length vertical list of your
notifications however each of those n
notifications could also have an M
length vertical list of cards creating a
sort of M by n like big scrollable space
you can just sort of watch the
interaction on the screen and kind of
realize you can page down the stream one
two three a couple more times and then
page to the right a couple times at that
point remembering how to get back to
where you were going from say row five
column four to row two column one became
a mental exercise in memory and
pathfinding which is not exactly ideal
when you were trying to rapidly triage
your notifications on your tiny little
wrist computer on the other hand the
context stream in Android wear 2.0 is
pretty simple to navigate like and 1x
the stream is ostensibly a single end
length list of Virgo
notifications unlike in 1x that's it
simple easy no pathfinding also just a
quick note we fixed one of the things
that bugged me the most about the old
stream where you could sort of like
flick from card to card to card but if
you had say seven or eight or nine or
ten notifications you actually could
only go one at once paginating through
them now we've made it possible to
vertically fling through those
notifications from top to bottom bottom
the top etc again sort of a big ol point
there for rapid usability now if you've
been thinking about the implications of
what I've been saying here you've
realized that a one-size-fits-all
approach might not actually fit all of
your content in fact because
smartwatches are very small it probably
will not fit all of your content and
some of it will be clipped to solve this
problem
Android wear 2.0 introduces expanded
notifications now in the new stream the
entire notification is a tap target
tapping that notification launches the
expanded notification experience this is
automatically rendered with where to
point owes new material guidelines which
allows you to provide a lightweight app
like experience to your users with
minimal effort all of the notification
content is arranged vertically in a
single script surface with the content
first followed by the primary action at
the end all the other actions that you
add to your notification are put in the
wearable action drawer component which
is a new component you can learn more
about by going to the Android wear 2.0
material design session at 3:00 p.m. now
what do you need to do to enhance your
notifications with this a new rich
experience nothing you get it all for
free this example here is one of the
simpler notifications that you can build
it has a text title icons an action 3
those things are actually necessary to
even build a notification in the first
place and you do this and all of that
nice material richness just comes along
for the ride that said if you want your
notifications to really pop to be
information rich and visually impactful
you may need to take full advantage of
the notification styles and templates as
you can see here expanded notifications
can be both information dense and
visually engaging you can use templates
like big text or big picture and you can
add extra pages to get even more
information into the
vacation itself I'm going to dive into
each of these in a second but you can
see here the level of richness and
visual diversity that you can get in an
expanded notification the first example
there was a big text notification which
you can see here with the text content
rendered in the stream and on the
expanded notification surface however
that notification also has an action
with the remote input that Dan was
talking about that we have had for a
couple years and choices which are
rendered directly on the expanded
notification itself which allows users
to take action directly or even respond
without having to talk or type from the
notification surface the next example
was a notification with two big picture
cards added to it whose images get put
straight on the expanded notification
surface which creates a sort of
immersive photo viewing experience just
from a notification now I'm about to
show you some code for all of this so
just look closely to remember what we're
actually going to be building this is
most of the code now those two images
are extra pages in the notification and
extra pages are actually notifications
in their own right so we're going to
create a notification first then we're
going to set that notification the style
to a big picture style and then attach
your image to the style with a simple
chain method call on it to make the
second big picture copy/paste works just
as well in code as it does in slides so
just do that and then to actually add
those pages we're going to need to
create a wearable extender and add those
to notifications as pages to it finally
we're gonna build the notification
itself by creating a builder setting the
title text and icons and finally
extending the notification with the
wearable extender that we built earlier
the rest is as simple as calling
notification manager notify and you'll
end up with an expanded notification
just like that with this rich photo
viewing experience now I do also want to
mention that extra pages can be
heterogeneous and you can mix mix and
match them to get exactly what you want
this lets you make rich notifications
like this one for a users ticket to see
space fights seven notification has
three extra pages containing a QR ticket
movie details and the plot synopsis as
you can see here all of those pages are
stacked vertically in the order that you
add them which essentially allows you to
use
extra pages as kind of building blocks
to construct the expanded notification
exactly as you want this makes it easy
to create an engaging and useful way or
experience without actually having to
make an app finally I'm going to talk
about one of the keynotes of where to
point OHS communications improvements
messaging style messaging style is an
entirely new notification style
introduced with Android wear 2.0 which
gives users a full back-and-forth chat
experience right in a notification when
a user taps into the expanded
notification itself they're going to
have access to the full context of their
conversation letting them get say right
back to the work chat from the day
before or the conversation with their
friends about how spaceflight 7 was
really awesome way better than the
prequels and maybe even lived up to the
originals you also notice that the chat
history includes sender names their
meaning that group conversations work
well too that said messaging style is
not just about formatting you could
theoretically do all of this yourself
with a big text and actually most of you
who have messaging apps already are and
just adding it as an extra page with
wearable extender the real key to
messaging style is actually how
messaging style and remote input work in
concert to give the user this experience
unlikely use other uses of remote input
replying the user replying won't
actually drop them out of the expanded
notification instead their response is
going to show up immediately inline on
the notification surface itself this
means that users are going to see their
messages instantly in front of them
before a round trip to the phone and
your app has completed this makes the
user experience very responsive and fast
and feels just very good all up if
you're a pre posts the notification with
new content it will also update in place
meaning that responses and replies by
other users also show up in this surface
without the user having to say go back
it go out and back in or reit app a
notification or anything it's all right
there giving that full back-and-forth
chat experience in the notification now
you're all savvy developers and have
probably noticed that these remote input
choices have been really good way better
than they
should be that you also may actually
have mentally linked that to David's
talk in the keynote if you're especially
savvy but the summary is that in the
future we are going to be bringing smart
report the smart reply feature from
inbox and allo to messaging style
notifications on wear meaning that you
as a developer can optionally give your
users dynamically generated quality
contextual responses to pick from all
for free good yeah it's very cool like
let's be clear
now I'm gonna talk about a little bit of
code to actually use messaging style and
to get it to work end to end you're
gonna need to create a reply action with
a remote input while technically not
necessary as I mentioned before the real
goodness of messaging style comes from
how the messaging style and remote input
work together just one on their own is
only gives you a sort of half of the
experience now this slide is actually
completely shamelessly copied from Dan
slide which is in turn shamelessly
copied from our developer documentation
including the Android version call-out
so all I'm going to say now is that you
need to do this and move on creating the
messaging style itself is actually very
simple you simply need to create a new
instance of messaging style with the
reply name that's going to show up when
the user replies in place and then add
all of the previous messages from the
conversation to the style by calling add
message with the text time and sender
finally you just need to build the
notification itself build it as normal
set the style to messaging style and add
the action that I completely glossed
over and call notify that's really
actually all there is to it if you
notice and we're paying attention that's
a little bit easier even than just
adding two pictures to a notification in
the first place now with that code we've
just gone through on your phone app you
are able to give you your users a full
back-and-forth chat experience on
Android wear that's it nothing else no
to go back to about 10 ish minutes ago
when Dan mentioned that there was a
better way of doing chat notifications
on the phone than using set remote input
history I have some good news we learned
from the path that remote input and
notification groups took and this time
we're going to be bringing a wear
feature to the phone
immediately instead of waiting a year or
two for it to show up messaging style on
the phone works just like on we're using
remote input for direct replies as you
can see here additionally if the user
does still want that full great app
experience that you've built and I'm
sure they will they just have to tap the
notification to deep link into your app
just like before now a quick note here
is that we put a lot of effort into
making messaging style work on Android
2.0 devices no matter what version of
Android they are paired to this means
that users running phones with an OS as
early as jellybean still get messaging
style goodness on Android wear all you
have to do is these three things in your
phone app first you have to use
notification compat builder as opposed
to notification builder second you have
to use notification compat messaging
style instead of notification messaging
style to be fair these are both things
that you're probably already doing
because compatibility is pretty
important here and then third and you're
probably already doing this if you're a
messaging app which i mentioned before
you need to add the user's chat history
as an extra page with wearable extender
to continue to support Android wear 1x
if you've done these things you're going
to end up with the following as shown by
these handy tiny little charts first on
Android wear 2.0 regardless of what
version the phone is running you're
gonna get messaging style everything
that I showed you full chat experience
right in the notification on where 1x
paired to any phone you're going to get
the standard notification card in the
stream and because you added that extra
page that's going to show up and your
users are still going to get their chat
history because messaging style is a
bespoke experience on Android wear 2.0
we don't actually show those extra pages
finally on the phone if your users
running em they're gonna get messaging
style notification and if they're not
notification compat ensures that they
still get the standard notification
experience all these things sort of
summed up together it mean that if you
use messaging style and these two other
things that I said you get the best of
all worlds no matter what device is
paired no matter what version those
devices are running so what actual steps
do you a developer need to take to work
with the chain
that we've made in Android wear to toe
first you need to make sure that
notification in the stream itself is
rapidly glanceable basically means focus
on the text second to get all this
expanded notification goodness and
really take full advantage of it use
extra content pages with wearable
extender to really like you structure
those building blocks and build the
experience out for your users third this
is also pretty important is that
notifications as you notice are dark now
that means that color spannabis and
display intents for your notifications
are actually maybe not going to work as
well as you would like because you need
to support dark backgrounds on 2.0 and
light backgrounds on 1x kind of hard to
find colors that work on both that said
quick call out here if you have a
standalone app or a wear app at all all
you have to do to make this work is just
check the API level at runtime or use a
resource qualifier to adjust your colors
as necessary you can still use them as
normal finally last bit of your a
messaging app make sure that you use
notification compat and messaging style
to give your users an awesome wear
experience without having to write the
wear app if any of this stuff interests
you and it probably should just go to G
Co slash where preview and you can get
the preview SDK device images and more
information about the new API is that
we're going to be launching all right
fantastic Thank You Alec sighs everybody
like still awake because we need to
stand up like shake a leg or tell us off
anything yeah we've got a few more
things that I want to cover here let's
switch places so I can poke the computer
a few more things we want to talk about
and then if we have time I'd love to
open it up for for questions let's get
through it first I want to draw your
attention okay let's make sure the
keyboard works so this guy here
malala's hair answered the question at
Google i/o 2012 when we first introduced
rich notifications with jellybean and at
the same time he introduced the ability
for users to block notifications that
they found inappropriate or spammy or
what have you and somebody got up at the
mic and said excuse me as an app can I
find out when the user has blocked my
notifications and this guy got up there
and said no
so actually this is pretty easy to do
the initial implementation actually you
couldn't do it but when a pops came
along which you may know is the
foundation of our you know permission
system we moved notification blocking
over to a pops because hey you know that
it's a new system facility for exactly
this sort of thing and it turns out that
because of some performance
optimizations in a pops you can from any
app at runtime do some you know funky
introspection and just check to see
whether an operation is allowed before
even invoking it it makes it much faster
to do certain kinds of operations so
yeah you can find out whether your
notifications have been blocked by
reflecting in Java so at the time we
were really worried that if apps knew
when their notifications were being
blocked the world would end it's 2016
four years later the world has not ended
so we said fine you know what let's just
make a real API for this because we
think they're actually some legitimate
uses of it so I'll get to that in a
second you can say notification manager
dot our notifications enabled real
easy-like are they has the azure block
my notifications are not and you don't
have to do those ugly hacks and you
don't have to go online and and put bad
stuff up and the reason that we
introduced this in addition to wanting
to reduce the number of places that
people had to resort to those attacks is
that you can't actually create a better
experience here's the situation a user
it feels like they're not getting
notifications from your app and they
don't understand why so they go into the
app then go into settings they see all
the boxes are ticked notifications are
turn on I don't know what's wrong one
start so now what you can do in your app
in your settings this is sort of a
mock-up that I use Gmail as a guinea pig
here but obviously you can do this in
your own app if the user goes in to
modify notifications settings your app
could go and sell hang on a second are
they you you block notifications at the
system level like there's nothing we can
do until you go and unblock that so you
can alert users to those conflicts and I
think that's a great user experience if
you do use this in some sort of abusive
way if you use this API to create some
kind of arms race with these are all you
block my notifications well I'm gonna
use a top-level system alert window or
whatever I will come and find you so
don't do it
let's see other stuff you want to know
about if you use builder and if you're
not using builder we have to have
another conversation because set latest
event info doesn't work anymore
if using builder we've changed a little
bit how the memory works that used to
whenever you call build it would
construct a new notification object
though it's a snapshot of its state and
hand that off to you now it actually
retains that object internally and just
gives you a pointer the big reason for
this is that notifications are huge they
didn't used to be but now people adding
wearable extenders and car extenders and
lots of big bitmaps and things like that
they're big objects and we didn't want
you to have to suffer that in your
memory partition every time you
construct it up a new notification so
when you're using a builder it is
holding on to that prototypical sort of
embryonic notification and when you call
build you just get a pointer to it if
you're not expecting that kind of
behavior the way things work in EM is
going to be possibly a little confusing
but this actually will make memory
better for you it makes memory better on
the system overall this is also
important when you are posting updates
to notifications we see a lot of people
in the field caching their notification
object and then using either poking
directly into the slots on that POJO or
using remote views methods to try to
update like progress bars and things
like that in the notification you can't
do that anymore I mean you can it's not
really gonna work because well I'll get
to the what happens to those remote
views in a second what you want to do if
you are posting updates to your
notification and you want to keep some
memory around as long as your app is
still live is hold on to the Builder the
builder will hold on to the notification
it'll be nice and fast to just go and
talk to the Builder and make your
changes there and call build again this
is a good bully pulpit for me to remind
you about features we've introduced over
the last couple of years that you may
not be using yet since L notifications
have been available on the lockscreen on
all L Android devices but users have
different tolerances for what kind of
content is appropriate on the lockscreen
lock screen is kind of a public place if
they've got you know pin password
fingerprint security potentially anybody
can you know pick your phone up off a
cab seat and and take a look at it so if
a user has opted into what we call a you
know hide sensitive content
notifications on the lock screen your
app is your
is just really not gonna say anything
interesting unless you specifically say
oh here's a public version here's a
version that's safe for the phone that's
found in the backseat of the cab or even
just you know laying face-up on your
desk when somebody else is sitting in
the same room so go ahead and use set
public version to supply a version of
that notification that's okay for users
who are security conscious or if it's
something like a weather widget or media
playback when you want it to be
available at all times say you know what
I'm just gonna set the visibility of
this notification to public and then
it's appropriate anywhere and you don't
have to make a separate version for it
something else I wanted to mention is
the way that Do Not Disturb works so
hopefully you've had a chance to play
around with the do not disturb that we
made really really good in marshmallow
the way that it knows what things are
phone calls or alarms to allow the user
to put the phone into alarms only mode
and get those alarms or into priority
mode and get phone calls from important
people is with your metadata in the
Builder and the two big ones are set
category and add person set category
allows you to say this is an alarm I
know I'm not the did the built-in
Android alarm clock app or the the OEM
is built in an alarm clock app but this
is you know I've got this cool app
called timely and it's got an alarm and
it should be treated as alarm as when
the user says go into alarms only mode
use that category to mark it that way
similarly add person is the way that
users are allowed to opt certain human
beings in to be able to break through
their priority settings and so you say
add person and we accept kind of
anything that we could use to look that
person up in the system contacts
database so you can throw yeah if you've
got fantastic if you've got a Content
you know a Content URI for that person
in the contacts database awesome we'll
just look it straight up but you can
also just supply an email address or
phone number and we'll go ahead and look
that up in contacts DB particularly if
your app doesn't really want to interact
with the Android contacts database but
it is phone number based you can give us
a phone number in the notification we'll
look it up if the user has starred that
contact that notification can bust
through priority mode which is a great
feature for users that want to tune out
of most things but there are some people
that should be able to get a hold of
them at any time I just wanna remind you
that media style exists that was the new
template that we introduced last time
around if you are building a music
player or anything that kind of
like in music players such as you know
background control of some sort of like
remote playback thing or video player
what have you used media style and we'll
take care of all the details of making
it look good on every platform version
and I mentioned earlier there was the
decorated custom view style if you feel
like you really need a custom remote
views there's a decorated media style
style I forget what it's called look at
the API Doc's I have to as well to be
able to get the system annotation of the
app name and so forth new actions along
with media the other thing that I want
to mention specifically about media
style is that if you are using set a or
if you were worried about using set
color which is the notification accent
color feature if you were worried about
using that because it made your media
playback notification look garish it
doesn't do that anymore so in n we are
only using that color to tint some of
the playback controls so it should be a
little bit safer to take your media
player's brand colors whether it's some
live in green or orange or what-have-you
and set that as the color on your media
style and it should look really good on
em this is where we have a very very
brief moment of silence for api's that
are no longer with us specifically all
of the direct access to remote views on
notification they're not gonna work
because we're not even creating them
time was when you created a notification
even with the Builder and called build
we would generate a whole remote views
that looked exactly like that
notification was going to appear on the
other side and then we would stuff that
thing into a parcel and push it all
through binder to the system server push
it all the system you want yeah we just
don't do that anymore
the remote views is not very if you have
a customer reviews and you said it those
slots will be there but if you use the
Builder methods these API is content
view big content view heads-up content
view are not there so use builder dot
set content and actually we renamed that
method to set custom content view to
make it better match the other stuff
that's been developed in the meantime
all right so this is for like two of you
in the room who are using notification
listener service one of them is you
because that's how we're works if you
have a notification listener service one
of the things that we noticed after
releasing this API 86 years ago is that
when we binded them from system UI we've
been buying it or bind them from the
notification manager
we've been binding for the lifetime of
the system because we sort of thought of
them as an extension of the system UI
they are really expensive so now if you
have a listener that only needs to
listen occasionally like you know it's
oh we're only listening when you're in
the car or we're only listening when
you're on a run we're only listening
when you're using this particular app or
experience you can say request unbind
like the users approved me as a
notification listener but I don't need
to be bound right now I'll let you know
when it's important to bind me again and
start sending me notifications so this
can really improve performance on the
device it can improve memory pressure I
think that's all the sundries there's
lots and lots of resources online
obviously dp3 is out you should go get
that apk go get that that package we
also have sample code we've updated them
to show off oops in the summary is our
standard active notification sample and
github and then the messaging service
update demos remote input I don't know
if it demos messaging style yet I think
that that is still like still damp with
how new it is so it's not a messaging
service yet but it will be the wear
Doc's do call that out the way Doc's
mention it okay so as developers what do
test your existing notifications on n
definitely if you have lots of
notifications that you're already
posting and you're not grouping them
please PLEASE group them nobody likes to
turn on a phone in the morning and get
36 notifications of all the stuff that
happened while you're asleep
ad direct reply where it's appropriate
where you can accept reply text and then
if you're using custom notifications do
look at that decorated custom view style
so users will get the benefit of the app
attribution and the expand affordance
and now it's clear stuff effects we're
just a little bit we're actually holding
a lot of sessions today so this is this
is a list if you want to come see more
starting with the big one what's new in
Android wear 2.0 and then a couple of
the others that I actually mentioned
during my portion of the talk also as
you know if you've missed anything all
of these talks are going to be available
on YouTube kind of shockingly quickly
yep
and finally the Android wear sandbox you
can go to two for more questions in live
demos it is the green square on this map
it also is just sort of like through
this wall and a little bit further
though probably go around instead of
actually through so we have time maybe
for like one or two live questions if
you want to get up on the mic and ask
otherwise we're going to be outside and
there's also we've enabled the new
Google spaces app for this talk many of
the talks today have spaces associated
with them where you can go and
communicate with the people in this room
and everybody else too I came to i/o to
talk about this topic poster examples of
your favorite notifications and least
favorite notifications but we've got a
couple minutes let's go ahead and take
some questions from the room yes go
ahead
the aware of notifications the new style
you said you can set the background
color of those cards correct using the
set color API which is actually what dan
talked about with regards to media style
specifically calling set color for your
notification will tint things on big
Android and will also on the littlest of
androids can set the background color
for all of those parts does it send it
directly or just tinted we use a
darkened version of it great thanks
so there's a practical limit that no
package can post more than 50
notifications you shouldn't really be
posting that many at all but you can
imagine a situation where you've got 5
accounts and you want to have 10
messages that seem as reasonable I don't
remember if we actually ended up
creating a limit but you'll notice that
you'll start to see system performance
suffer if you're posting all 50 into
that group at the same time not least
because it's not useful the users not
going to want to triage that much stuff
our recommendation is on the order of 5
maybe as many as 10 only your
observation of user behavior we'll see
will tell you what is actually gonna be
useful to people so I don't know what
the underlap is between those two
between those two api so we should talk
we should talk after and and maybe that
sounds like the kind of thing that would
be good there's a bug tracker
specifically dedicated to the Android
and previews that's a good place to
raise that kind of issue because we are
triaging as bugs pretty aggressively and
and taking action on them Thanks thank
you
no there's no there's no broadcast so
you can't find out like you know what we
really don't want you to do is to try to
like min/max the user's behavior and try
to respond in real-time to you know when
the user becomes you know so enraged
with a block notifications it's
expressly created so that you can do
things like I showed in the screenshot
when the user has problems you can say
well here that's one of the reasons that
you might be having those problems so
there's no listener I mean you can check
at any time yeah yes it's we're 2.0
availability question so we're 2.0 is
going to be available later this fall
the to be fair also the Developer
Preview is available right now on the
site that I linked gqo slash where
preview thank you alright I think that's
it thank you so much we'll see you on
spaces and thank you for throwing up
you